des murs décrépis des enseignes
vieillissante des magasins fermés ou en
passe de l'être
le centre dauphine a perdu de son éclat
et toujours pas de travaux en vue les
copropriétaires attendent semble-t-il
l'aboutissement d'un projet de
restructuration lancée par de mystérieux
investisseurs
les commerçants locataires encore
présents honteux peu d'informations sur
l'avenir du centre on sait effectivement
que la commission de sécurité
apparemment n'a pas donné son accord que
des travaux devrait être rétablie à
partir de février 2020 mais on n'a pas
plus de d'un fossé que des bruits de
couloir comme quoi effectivement un
investisseur rachèterait tout pour
refaire des logements au-dessus heureuse
créer de nouvelles cellules peut être un
peu plus haut de gamme en bas donc ça
c'est une très bonne chose
la seule préoccupation effectivement
qu'on essaie le chiffre qui ne fait que
baisser la fréquentation qui n'est fait
que baisser et par contre nos charges
sont toujours les mêmes contacté le
syndic des copropriétaires n'a pas voulu
nous en dire plus sur ce projet ni nous
autorisée à filmer dans les allées du
centre une copropriété des cas yang
selon les commerçants
je pense que les propriétaires sont un
petit peu responsable d or et lui est à
mettre un petit peu la main à la poche
depuis depuis quelques années pour pour
que le centre n'en viennent pas une
situation pareille
le centre dauphine sept commerçants qui
a cru et y croit encore m'installer ici
depuis quatre ans elle a préféré faute
de vision sur l'avenir ne pas renouveler
son bail commercial
j'ai un petit peu le sentiment en fait
que les indépendants qui sont dans cette
galerie même depuis très longtemps ou
sont pas très respecté et ne seront pas
les bienvenus dans ce nouveau projet
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de partir par
mes propres moyens même si ça me coûte
parce que ça me coûte énormément
d'argent de partie mais je trouve ça
relativement injuste qu'on met quand
même même pas eu la décence de venir
m'expliquer
ce qui allait se passer ici inauguré en
octobre 1973 ce centre commercial du
coeur de ville faisait alors la fierté
de son maire ces deux réalisations la
rue muller le centre de jeux vidéo ça
fait plus un peu molle à l'ancienne du
coup c'est pas mon niveau pour acheter
nécessaire sinon on ne va pas pour venir
au centre de films quoi j'y viens
souvent pour le monoprix mais la galerie
commerciale j'avoue que je gifle et
jamais un tour aujourd'hui de boudé par
les clients le centre est devenu
encombrant y compris pour la mairie mais
cela devrait changer avec ce fameux
projet dont personne ne veut parler
nous accompagnons ce projet privé et les
privés ont paru quand ils le
souhaiteront mais sachez qu'il y a un
projet qui tient à coeur au maire de
dijon
effectivement pour ce coeur de ville
qu'il soit encore plus dynamique
françois rebsamen intéressés par ce
projet secret nous voilà rassurés du
côté de l'opposition municipale
on réfléchit sans arrière pensée
politique à l'avenir du lieu un cabinet
a même planché sur une alternative
une façon pour laurent bourguignat
d'accélérer la rénovation du centre
je regrette que depuis 20 ans unis s'y
passe rien
par contre ça doit pas rester un projet
de secret il doit être présenté aux
dijonnais parce que on est sur un lieu
stratégique au coeur du coeur de ville
et il faut qu'on coco construire ce
projet avec avec les dijonnais l'avenir
du centre dauphine pourrait donc
s'éclaircir mais au vu d'autres galeries
marchandes de la ville le malaise est
peut-être plus profond dans ce complexe
près de la moitié des magasins sont
fermés